russia doesn't have the death penalty
and outside of moscow nowhere else on
earth is this court acknowledged to have
any legitimacy but after a trial lasting
a few days and their confessions to
being mercenaries aiden astin and sean
pinner were convicted and sentenced to
death for terrorism by the so-called
donetsk people's republic a moroccan man
sardone brahim received the same
sentence the two britons were members of
the ukrainian marines they were captured
in the fight to defend mario
in january this year i traveled to meet
them in the frozen trenches near where
they were captured the invasion hadn't
started but it felt like it was getting
more likely every day
we've already had two guys injured on my
position
both men knew their fighting for the
ukrainians was controversial but both
could prove they were professional
contracted soldiers not mercenaries yeah
i'm married a ukrainian i've got every
much right to be here and the guys it's
taken me a long time to integrate here
so the guys know i'm not
you know a war tourist or a war junkie
and i'm with an organized unit i'm with
the government and i'm with a contracted
soldier tried to steer away from that
sort of volunteer unit and militia shawn
originally from watford was a section
commander he'd been living in ukraine
for four years
back then he couldn't have known how
accurate his prediction on this war
would be
if they come across the ball that we're
outgunned we haven't got air superiority
a superior superiority we don't have a
naval fleet very strong naval fleet
but
ukrainians fight so we'll give them a
bloody nose that's for sure
and they're coming close you know
aidan aslin from newark was on a third
tour with the marines
he said he considered his life here my
fiance is ukrainian um i've got a house
like in ukraine i'm building a family
i asked what it was like being in the
ukrainian military
when i first came like guys were like a
bit like suspicious like like why are
you here like
like are you crazy
um but after a while like i assimilated
um learned the language um i i still
speak like
i still speak like a baby when i speak
russian but i speak enough to get the
message across and also i understand a
lot more than i speak
so
now guys just like see me as any other
ukrainian guy
the convictions have been widely
condemned and the hearings dismissed as
a show trial
however it doesn't mean that the
russian-backed separatist state leaders
would not carry out the sentence
neither they or president putin have
shown any concern about consequences
for anything in recent times stuart
ramsey sky news eastern ukraine